c'est le projet phare de l'ue fr simone
veil santé de l'ue vs qu l'institut en
santé parra sport connectés qui sera lui
suture mureaux cet établissement prévu
pour 2024 sera dédiée au sport et
handicap
d'infrastructures spécialisées sur le
suivi médical la formation des
professionnels de santé et la recherche
et développement technologique
on est sur une dimension technologique
des exosquelettes de leur thèse de la
prothèse des fauteuils roulants et
également des aides techniques pour
pouvoir pratiquer du sport ainsi qu lui
sera la structure opérationnelle le site
l'endroit le carrefour où physiquement
les gens se rencontreront à la fois les
chercheurs les enseignants les sportifs
et sportives tout-venant les sportifs de
haut niveau et donc c'est cette vie en
commun cet échange permanent qui sera
source d'innovation des sportifs de haut
niveau des chercheurs des professionnels
de santé tous sont rassemblés pour le
3ème symposium sport santé de l'ufr
simone veil de l'ue vs qu l'occasion
chaque année d'échangés sur une
thématique cette année c'est le sport et
le handicap le thème du handicap est un
thème prioritaire est majeur de
l'université et de l'ufr des sciences de
la santé
et donc c'est effectivement un thème
dans lequel nombreux projets
scientifiques sont développés en
particulier l'institut du sport
connectée du professeur françois genest
autres nouveautés présentées lors de ce
symposium la création du département
universitaire de médecine des activités
physiques et sportives